we are learning more and more Pat about
ex mi6 officer Christopher Steele who is
the individual believed to have prepared
the memos claiming that Russia had this
blackmail file on president-elect Donald
Trump the u.s. president elect of course
said it's fake news phony stuff none of
it exists but we are now learning about
the high credibility of Christopher
steel BBC News correspondent Paul woods
said he understood that mr. Steele is
not only considered to be highly
credible but that he actually left his
home in the middle of last week before
he was publicly named and is now in
hiding for fear of his life he
reportedly asked his neighbor to look
after his three cats when he left with
his family the BBC correspondent said he
had been shown the memos about Trump in
October of last year when Steele was
already fearing for his life of course
Donald Trump blackmailed the dossier to
Nazi propaganda fake news spread by sick
people here's an important question I've
been sort of thinking about over the
long wknd pass if it's also hard to
believe and it's a stretch in its way
out there why did the intelligence
community decide it was serious and
reliable enough to brief both Obama and
Trump and again this doesn't tell us
anything about the content of the
material but clearly they thought it was
serious enough to brief them and yet we
still see the trumpets acting like
nothing's going on I think it's just
easier to reject these claims all
together rather than digging into the
weeds of what's actually going on in
these allegations yeah that's when you
really start to get into some trouble
and steel has been caricatured of some
partisan hack but we now are hearing
from one intelligence source who said
Steele is very credible that he's sober
he's cautious he's meticulous he has a
formidable record a former a foreign
office official who has known steel for
25 years said the idea that his work is
fake or a cowboy operation is false the
American intelligence community is
taking this seriously we now have heard
confirmation from both DNI clapper and
John Brennan CIA directors that indeed
Trump was briefed on it there's no fake
news here is there and again fake news
is different from Trump likes urinating
on whim
and right I mean we're not talking about
the specifics of the file we're saying
the idea that the entire briefing is
fake that the existence of the dossier
is fake it's 0% believable I think
that's what goes the idea that
Christopher steel would be on the run
here he's one of the biggest experts
when it comes to Russia in this section
of British intelligence and you've seen
what the US the UK do to people who
leaked information yet Seattle Ian
Assange Edward Snowden Chelsea Manning
right so this is just in the bestest
interest of his own safety yeah we have
to be paying attention to that as well
that's a really good point